um I think to each her own I really do
think it's it's not the answer for
everyone and I don't like to think that
people you know to make that choice
because of the career I think is not it
doesn't really guarantee you anything so
I wouldn't want people to put all their
eggs in that basket for the career on
the other hand to hear someone who is a
passionate and committed writer say you
know what this gives me time to do some
writing this gives me time to work on a
manuscript and that's how I'm thinking
about the year I think that that's a
wonderful and sensible thing to do
it's great if you can get a fellowship
to do that and you know it used to be
when there are fewer of them that a
fellowship you know a paid year in
graduate school made a tremendous amount
of sense made more sense than anything
else in a way as a way to try to get a
first book done
I think study is good I think community
is good do I think that you know there
are positive creative communities in all
MFA programs no in some absolutely
absolutely and so you see people who
make their communities of readers for
life or who are able to apprentice
themselves with a teacher who changes
their life that was certainly the case
for me studying with derek walcott he
was you know the only poetry teacher I
ever had and he was the teacher who
changed my life and that and that was
that so if you're lucky enough to make
that connection then absolutely of
course it's worth it
I think also you know for MFA programs
that have a classroom component that's
not just a creative writing workshop so
that in other words designate some time
in your life to you know really really
really read and and and soak up a lot I
think that's great
although I also think for any artist and
for any poet there is no substitute for
Auto didacticism you know that that you
have to have a reading hunger that leads
you on your own path that that's a very
very very important part to my mind of
being an artist
there are so many poets who make a life
in the work and do their work but that's
not necessarily measurable in
conventionally successful ways you look
at there's a very great poet who died
about a year ago named Christopher
Christopher Gilbert who wrote a book
called across the mutual landscape and
he published this book about 25 years
ago it was a book a kind of an
underground hit with them so I know many
poets for whom this is a secret special
book for them and he was a practicing I
think psychotherapist he had another
professional life apparently he was
writing poems and kept writing poems but
the legacy as we know it now is that one
book but it was a very beautiful and
important book so you know how do you
put that against the career of someone
like an Adria and rich right who
publishes her first book of poems in the
Yale series of younger poets when she's
in college you know she's 20 or 21 or
something when Todd picked that book and
now as an elder she's had a whole steady
productive I mean that's that's a life
in in the arts that's another kind of
success and so even though you know poem
for poem there are many rich poems that
are indelible and incredibly important
to me but I also learned so much from
the whole career the whole life so
there's so many different ways that it
it plays out you see and in different
ways that I would think of of success so
I think that that it's a mysterious
perseverance that keeps you going
when I teach creative writing I'm a
great believer in free writing in you
know that whole concept of taking the
sensor off your shoulder and of when you
feel stuck especially just trying to let
it all out to to write without stopping
and then deal with the fixing up later
that can be very very difficult because
sometimes you know it's page upon page
day upon day week upon week of dreck and
you know sometimes it's unbeautiful it's
uncompelled and you just have to keep
moving through it you have to keep
moving forward but I think that that
kind of just letting it come and knowing
that somewhere in the tumble down the
river there's going to be a stone that's
that's that it's got a particular Sheen
to it and that's what you build on I
think that's the most important thing is
not to stop
I think you know one of the important
things that I've seen in places where
topo 'try is taught well to young people
is to realize that they have got they
they're not yet afraid of it and they
are still unselfconsciously in love with
sound and also they're fantastic
memorizers kids can memorize so much
because you know their brains are supple
and and and spongy so I think to have to
memorize and recite before you think of
it as cod liver oil is is a very very
very good thing because then you have
that wonderful experience of possessing
a poem and also a feeling how it exists
in the voice which sometimes makes it
very exciting in a way you know you can
sort of experience the rhythms in a way
that might not always be clear on a
first reading on the paper and then
finally I would say just the continued
and avid teaching of poetry and to teach
that you know yes we go back to it we
study it we try to unpack how it works
but we also need to take it in as music
and I think that that that remembering
that aspect of reading poetry is is very
important
when I see some of the cool things let's
say that you know the Poetry Foundation
is doing or you know when I see these
things where oh you know here's here's
Langston Hughes on a street in Harlem
here he is with Charles Mingus you know
doing his the weary blues I mean why not
take digital and multimedia capabilities
as a way of bringing poems into three
dimension it's great I am recorded and
it was such a pleasurable project a
podcast for the Poetry Foundation where
they do a literary tour of Washington DC
which is my hometown which is that you
know you're supposed to they they paste
it out you're supposed to put on your
iPod and go out and start walking and
see and learn about the literary
heritage and you know you can stop in
front of whatever historical site you
know this is the corner where Walt
Whitman would would shyly wave to
Abraham Lincoln and then they there's
Lincoln's voice in your ears while you
stand on that corner what's not to like
about that